ATEFUL A
YOU ARLI IN
M
O GORYNEFORE I FLORIDAHES  I RIL
MEANWHILE, HURRINE MOVING THRA.G
TR
IN NEM
300,000 CUSTOMERS
ARE WITHOUPOWER.
RESIDENTS IN FOUPROVINCES FACE
ONCH ON, WE WILL GETDA
SEEMS TO BGETTRONGER? Y THAT  CT
'STOGETHER
BIT MORE L
SU45,  MILES PER.ATCHES F A AND
TH THEE ISWE ANTICIPATE THIS STA
R THE CAYMANELY LA SUN IME
SURFACMP IN THMID-TOER REGION.
AHE
U START TO GO DOWNNS OF THAT H
CONTT ELTHAT'S THAT FUEL THA SRE
EVERALONCE IO THLFMEIN AND ALSO
TOO, YOU AREKI
HERE SUSPECT MUCH R  T
PATE THA
BECOME A MAJORCANE AS IT
AST NO
WE WILL  AN IT L
IN THEINDAYS.
>> THANK YOUT'S PIVO CARLOS BEEN
., IT TAKES A LOT FOR
ARNS TO SNAP OUT OF IT AND
TH U AOUFOOU R HOPAST FROMMERGEL
WEST COAST AS WELL
FLORIDKE AND THARATIONSY
MONDAY.TAKING SOMOF
THOSE FOLKS THAT ARE GETTING
BOTTLED WATER INREA.
NOAT AUTHORITIESE KEMEWIOD TACUE
UNTHE GOF OFCY FOR 24 NDCT
ONAL GUA
HE LOLE KEYS. AFT HURRICCAG LLS
ARLOS SUAREZ, THANK YOSO N CHIN
SURGE.EACANANG DAMANM
WE WANT TO TALK TO SOMEBODY ON
THE GROUNDHE
JOINING US FROM THE EMERGENCY
MENT CENTER IS
IFAX, A. IS BEEN A
NOVA SCOTIA IME CANADA CANES HER
POWER OUTAGE
ANOUR ONS TO TRA ARE W H HALIFAN
FOA WHILE YET.  ARE GOE SUFFERIS
U AR VER
VERY EAR
DAMAGE FORE.OUND ABOUT AN
ROOF COLLAPSEAT 1
A COMFORTENTER.
ET THEIR
CEES CHARGED ANDHI
OF COURSE, WE ENCOURAGE KS ARINS
E FE
TO CLE I
>> AT THISGE WL ITINTO T HIF
HAE
A NUMBERF
WE HAVE LOCTION
HAPPENING IN HALIFVEBR
M TO HAVLKS HOMELESS LIVINMPMEN.
MHEM TOELTERS ALA BE SECUREO GD
ANTAL COITWA WAV
ORM SURGE IS V
ALTHNTIC C
SO PEOPLE VI IL IEAR
PROVISIONST EP
LONGER.PONGATIOD
FORE, ALL OF OUR R
, UTILITIES AND NOVA SCOTI
LITO
EFIVYTHING
THMA
SURVIVE THIS ANDE I PREY ARENGEN
FOLKS HAVE HEEDED THE WARNIN,  T
YOURS ARE GOING TO EXPERIENC I T
INTACT? TRYINSTEPS W RE THE YO
STORMSTEN. SQ
CAD SOUTHERN U. SEOATHGENERAHI
WEN.ROTECT OURERS,
WE ARE GETTI TAV